I would talk about a younger generation that's coming up
that will build a community
that's not based around nation states
and based around limiting
and creating divides between people.
I would sort of look towards building a community
that's one that has a,
recognizes their shared future together
and really can work together to build that.
Whether they're from, you know,
the slums of Kibera in Nairobi
or from big cities like London
or, you know, rural United States,
you know, I think we're all one people,
and we can all work together,
and so I would really talk about how
that's what needs,
that's what the world needs right now.
We need to recognize
that we have far more in common
than we do have differences.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.